so like going like i guess moving from
made in the best one thing i've noticed
is that you always try to do something
new with like every new project that you
take on i guess that's why you put a lot
of experimental stuff into made in abyss
um and i feel like
tower of god right it's that's just like
dubstep which is like so far removed
from what you were doing and made in the
abyss like how how did that come about
like did you have to listen to like a
lot of dubstep to like study it or do it
would do that just like coming did they
tell you or was that your decision to be
like i'm going to put a bunch of [ __ ]
dubstep
used to go to a lot of [ __ ] raves
i just feel like
no no um like one of the people i worked
with
okay pre-story again but uh
like yeah so perth has like a massive
dumb drum drum basically we've already
get in the background yeah yeah yeah
yeah but we'll pendulum from there for
example oh yeah
of course like he has a great scene and
uh yeah so i when i went to whopper
i got introduced because i was like oh i
love video game music and that's it sort
of thing yeah but then um one of my
friends one of my really really close
best friends that i still you know we're
still really really close today yeah so
we know each other [ __ ] is getting on 13
years now yeah but um yeah he used to be
like oh well we're going to [ __ ] you
know we're going to like this like hotel
bar to go to rave and i've got a track
and one of the dj's is playing one of my
jumpers
come on and then yeah just do a bunch of
[ __ ] like vodka cruises and whatnot
just sounds like a [ __ ] energizer
bunny on the [ __ ] floor like for like
three or four hours and it would be
great and so i kind of kept that guy and
when i moved here obviously that you
know this big kind of edm
yeah i just like to imagine you were
like defcon or something and you're just
standing there like they don't know i'm
a florist
[Laughter]
but that that um that culture of um of
dance music and especially um like
hardcore yeah well yeah the liquid drum
bass or dark drum bass [ __ ] just kept
with me
so like
if you think about like kind of those
elements where it's either like very
very fluid sort of synthesizers or it
can be like it like there are some
[ __ ] hardcore like music
like in that genre yeah yeah yeah yeah
if you've like been to like uh i'd
rather just like there's there's so many
like there's so many like examples but
you know if you hear like um
i can't even think of like i remember
going to a couple of gigs uh in either
south east london when i was living here
yeah and the [ __ ] base that comes out
of some of these like venues yeah yeah
there's like speakers like
i went to this warehouse gig once i
can't remember where because it's been
so long ago but now but like i remember
like just walls and walls of speakers
yeah meters and then because it's like a
three-story warehouse they've got
something
yeah yeah right [ __ ] base that comes
out of those mixers yeah when you're on
the dance floor you know obviously you
had a couple of your vodka tonics or
something like that man you just like
it's it's wetting it's yeah you you feel
you feel every atom in your body just
like shake it yeah yeah yeah especially
the base like it's a [ __ ] physical
reaction biblical man it's so good yeah
yeah and so like you know the bass is
good when you don't hear it you just
feel it yeah that's such a good
adjective yeah biblical i'm going to use
that more
often
it's resonating in your chest
it's really good
it feels awesome and it sounds great as
well yeah
this is the chicken sandwich
it's so good that jesus had to get
involved
there's a little spiritual um but yeah
so um
that culture and that that feeling yeah
um still is with me even though i write
a lot of uh orchestral music as well
yeah yeah it came to when it came to
tower of god um if you look at the manga
because mamawa i'm like manga is um it's
colorized yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so if
you look at the color palette for tower
of god in the manwa it's actually very
minimalist yeah like three or four like
very big bold colors on yeah on a panel
and then you go back
so you see these really interesting like
some of the characters are sometimes
just silhouettes against like a huge
beautiful background right right in
front of a giant creature or something
like that so there's a there's a as a
composer it's like kind of a bit of a
wet dream it's really good yeah yeah so
um if you think about taking really bold
colors that are contrasting and trying
to put them together in a musical
experience yeah like you you can split
it into let's say a frequency range you
can go high mid low yeah so if you have
uh i did a theme for one of the
characters called rachel yeah and her
theme is literally just harp so there's
harp in the middle there's like dial-up
style tones on top and then just this
bass comes in to just kind of punch you
in the face essentially right chest
cavity and so like that sort of like
dubstep with heart for example like how
can we find interesting combinations
that still kind of relate back to this
idea of frequency spectrums being kind
of split up to represent very minimalist
but maximalist style coloring in the
panels yeah yeah yeah yeah i think so
like you know you have these kind of
pretty heartburn
yeah
yeah
these sorts of um
uh like also radical changes in texas as
well like that suits tara god in my mind
at least yeah yeah no i definitely do
yeah when you when you handed it to them
and you're like here it is they were
like were they like whoa
it was kind of interesting because um we
did essentially what you could call
almost like a concept album we did like
13 tracks we're like we're going to put
together 13 contrasting tracks that's
quite a lot of tracks it was a big
investment yeah uh but like we did like
like the first 13 tracks as like sort of
prove the concept saying like this is
what we want to do this is how we want
to do it with this style of choir and
you know this harp and dubstep idea and
want to you know punch people in the
face with like
my beats and [ __ ] and uh they were all
for it which again that's [ __ ] lucky
and thank you to them for like actually
just being like being cool with it yeah
yeah
like when you explain stuff in music i'm
like yeah okay all right
i have achieved the impossible yeah i
feel like i feel like
if i was the exec i'd be like you sound
like you know it yeah
i'll just not believe it you mentioned
the word
biblical minimalist and then
maximalistic
within like one second and i was like
that sounds like you you know what's up
look into my eyes
i just like i'm trying to i'm like yeah
okay i hop
of course yeah of course of course yeah
yeah at the end you also need to you
know execute the concept yeah of course
yeah so like you know because obviously
everything's done kind of in a computer
so to speak until you go to the
recording process
you're also showing a demo you're not
showing like the full
realization yeah yeah sort of thing so
then you've got to potentially risk you
know going and finding the right
musician finding the right space yeah
within the right budget of course as
well are you the one handling all of
this is the oh i mean it's not like i've
got um
sort of the music supervisor director
yeah yeah yeah that we we work with
every day right so if you need someone
to play the half right you need someone
to record it you're like i know a guy or
well you're like please find me a half
past well this is the the lucky part
about going to a music college because
you know everybody you get to know much
musicians yeah so like a couple of
composer friends that i went to
with uh and
so i'm going to come back to it but uh
like you know
it's all [ __ ] it's all connected man
my man's got
um yeah no so like for example like uh
when i went to undergrad and whopper
like i had a couple of friends and stuff
that like i started working with on
tarot cards so yeah um you know uh matt
mclean feeding here is his name and we
did some jump bass stuff for um for
tower of god yeah yeah like really
really nice yeah and then um
i need some musicians because i went to
yeah the rcm here in london right and
like those those
student musicians are bloody good yeah
yeah those yeah super musicians of the
rcm become
you know they have a very very good
chance of becoming working musicians
yeah
right you hope so you know
there is a there is a really like they
are
beautiful musicians and
because you because you're just
basically breaking bread with these guys
for two three four years yeah you're
going to the rcm bar and you're getting
hammered with these guys all the time
and so you know you have like this
connection because you know in the same
way that we kind of you know broke a
little break a little bread over yeah
over about 600 gin tonics you know you
do the same with like the music and
stuff they're good friends and but they
also just they just they they come to
work so yeah so it sounds like every
aspect of the entertainment industry
yeah yeah you can be good at what you do
but also you need to go out and talk to
people yeah
that's super important and so
um when it came to certain projects like
this like tara got like oh
i mean valeria was the harp player and
she she does not need classical heart
but she also does improv harp so i can
just give her like you know i could
almost give him some you know really
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] like sheet music
where i was like i've done my best to
like make it so that it doesn't look
like an absolute insult but
feel free to like just interpret this
in a non-shitty way right